if you had to change the format of the
world championship finals between two
players what would your format look like
oh if i ever got there i don't think i'd
care too much about the formula i'd just
be happy to get there but
i haven't i don't have too many specific
thoughts on the on the
format i would say from my personal side
i think the current form of this all
right i heard a new proposal of holding
a match in several sets so three sets of
four games which sounds interesting as
well because then
you might keep the match interesting
like you lose one set but then you can
win another set and it
keeps it interesting so i heard that a
carlsen will not play unless
like playing conditions change like the
format so i hope they might change it
into something you like so you'll play
of course that's what i like to see
no i don't i simply don't think it
exists
because
there's always maybe some
format that favors some of the players
and the others are better in rapid
someone is better in
knockouts other than round robin so i
don't think it exists but
well the main thing is i guess
is once it starts you can make changes
so that i i believe that's the it's
because it's it's been in the history
it's happened many times and i don't
think it's a good idea so
i believe it's only a good idea to
change to make changes after it's over
with the cycle i am not sure it's very
good to change
this requirement in last time last
moment
i think
magnus he played very good match against
jan in
in last format but he played not very
good match against fabiano and kayaking
i think for him it's a little bit boring
to play in the same format
well i think a match is necessary like
you kind of have to beat the
world champion in
in a match in order to become one
yourself
the tradition has always been
classical games right at least twelve it
used to be twenty four used to be longer
many years ago i just want to see
classical chess i think it's the most
important
time control
so shortening it doesn't
make much sense to me
if you
if the score is tight after that then
you keep going on the classical i just
don't think mixing shorter time control
makes that much sense but
we'll see it's it's more attractive also
to the fans who have blitz and rapid but
personally to me i like classical yes i
am probably
everybody agrees that maybe it should be
a little bit
faster
so
there are a lot of formats that could be
more interesting but it should be
discussed of course it's defeated so
i think it's not very bad the format
that we have now but i think it could be
more better and entertaining also
it's hard to give it definitive answers
but
first of all i think
seth's idea
best of three sets or best of five sets
it sounds like a great idea in the sense
that there wouldn't be
any game without stakes
i haven't thought about that because i'm
still
quite a long
and far away from the playing the world
championship match but uh
to be honest i don't think there's
anything wrong with the current format
if you want to to see who is the best
player in the world it has to be
reasonably long match of classical chess
i don't believe too much in
other formats in terms of rabbit or
blitz for
for the title because
i think the best player in chess is is
the best player in classical chess not
so much in
in rabbit and blitz i really like the
classical forward because i think we
have some safer championships for
rabbits and for blizz and i don't really
think it's it's a good idea to mix up
but
for sure it's i think it's wrong to
change the rules like in the middle of
the cycle so this has to be discussed
let's say right after i don't know let's
say right after the mesh or something
yeah but then we at the very beginning
of the new cycle so we make sure that
we you know we play to qualify and we
play okay the match uh with some same
regulations same you know same time
control same i don't know
same rules like sofia rules and so on
that's
that's obviously a good question because
uh
i know time
time is now different
you know comparing to what was like okay
let's say 100 years ago and maybe we
really need to seek for a new format but
this is
i would say that we have like
it's more than
i mean almost 150 years tradition of
holding classical nations and
uh i think
this is quite priceless i don't know
what the ideal um setup for the world
championship match is
i think there are
a lot of formats that could be tried
but
as i've said for for many years i think
the one that we have now is
is one of one of the worst when when it
comes to
[Music]
you know selecting
the best player
specifically i would say that
there are
two
too few games
also it's kind of
kind of too easy to
to defend when you have so long to
to prepare and
i think it's
really all set up to decrease the
chances that the best player
wins
so i in general i would say
more games
less time would be
would be better
definitely
you